this is the sound egg it's a surround
sound isolation chamber what I'm sitting
in is a plastic egg with sound isolating
foam surround sound speakers as a
subwoofer at my back and you basically
put on a video and sit inside of it and
you're completely immersed by whatever
you're watching and then you step
outside of it and it's like whoa what
happened all the sound went away it's
pretty cool and the styling on it's
really neat because it's a lot like
those old eggs that we had in the 70s in
your bedroom or whatever so they can
make it any color you want to so they do
all different types of custom colors and
it's a great gift for somebody who may
be part of your family that listens to
really annoying music that you can't
stand you can put them inside one of
these things and they can crank it up
and watch their video and you never have
to hear it outside of just many a few
feet and it's also probably really
effective torture device like we've got
the police going right now but just a
couple seconds ago there's some Dave
Matthews and if you stuck being this
thing with Dave Matthews cranked up for
a few hours I've lose my mind so
whichever purpose you decide to get it
forward pretty effective
excuse me
you